another 1500 U.S soldiers and Marines
will be arriving on the southern border
as soon as next week to join the 2500
National Guard troops that are already
there the reason it goes back to covid
former president Donald Trump made no
secret of his disdain for migrants he
used the coveted emergency to enact a
plan to turn back migrants to Mexico
before they could ask for Asylum called
title 42 which President Joe Biden kept
in place but on May 11th the covet
emergency is officially over and
authorities expect as many as 11 000
people will try to cross the border
without documents each week but Biden
has changed the rules of what will
happen when they get here now anyone
caught crossing without permission will
be presumed to not qualify for Asylum
making it easier to send them back
immediately unless they can prove they
were denied asylum in another country
immigration Advocates are outraged at
Biden's record so he's been very
effective at
um
taking away access to Asylum and
limiting access to Asylum um and and
um
yeah and and so in in my view not great
in protecting the rights of of of of
migrants and Asylum Seekers and honoring
their Humanity the Biden Administration
says it is allowing access for people to
claim Asylum if they make a very hard to
get appointment at the border crossings
it has also changed the rules so that 30
000 migrants from Cuba Haiti Nicaragua
and Venezuela can come to the U.S every
month if they apply and have a local
sponsor the military is downplaying the
significance of the move military
personnel will not directly participate
in law enforcement activities while this
request is for 90 days I would point out
that DOD has supported DHS on the
Southwest border for 18 of the last 22
years and every year since 2006. a
long-standing issue that has divided the
nation and has seen presidents from both
parties promising to stop the flow of
people so far to little effect Patty
culhane Al Jazeera Washington